great food is all around us even in
hidden or completely unexpected places
but when one bite is life-changing the
journey is worthless first stop a
delicious surprise at one very special
car wash
[Music]
getting your car washed is normally a
bit of a chore but here in Northridge
people are getting more car washes than
necessary and that's because of
something delicious lurking inside they
always say what we say the car wash how
come what happened how did you get here
it's really funny because nobody would
think that we are here I'm Lillian and
I'm the owner of Lillian spreading
sweets
and we're located inside Lillian opened
her restaurant in the car wash for one
simple reason
she knew that being located in a car
wash would provide foot traffic and some
new clients when you walk into cruisers
you were confronted by the smells of
little tree air fresheners steering
wheel covers and other car cleaning
paraphernalia but you are also
confronted with the smell of home-cooked
Filipino food Filipino food is simple
but delicious with a lot of pork chicken
and beef and rice of course we cannot
keep our food without rice we are famous
for our hollow hollow our hollow hollow
they always say is the best in the West
it is to die for
as someone who ate three hollow hollows
in 24 hours I can attest it's really
great
Filipino food tends to be overlooked
internationally but it's gearing up to
be the next big thing in the culinary
world on average in a day I will sell
about 300 meals cooking is really a
passion for me
yeah because if you are not passionate
with what you're doing then you won't be
able to succeed I'm really so grateful
and thankful that I have my team because
without them I am nothing I think that's
my secret so the next time you treat
yourself to a car wash
you can splurge am more than just a
pine-scented air freshener you can
splurge on that empanada scented plate
of Filipino food guaranteed to make your
car smell better than a little air
freshener ever could now that the car is
nice and shiny it's time to fill up on
gas and some more amazing food all in
one stop
at the Bombay Frankie company you'll
find Hiram and his staff making Indian
food at a gas station
Hiram care to explain okay the reason
why we chose this particular gas station
is because our families actually in the
gas station giving you store business we
had this space for you for quite a while
and we thought well what a great
launchpad traditionally what you might
find it is unhealthy non fresh fare and
when you're coming across something
that's not only fresh but it's true to
the most raw ingredients so when we
start with that completely off the wall
pairing you're gonna be starting from a
really low point so all you can go is
high and higher and we're trying to just
set the bar really high since they've
opened the Bombay Frankie company has
received both critical and commercial
success definitely our most popular item
is the Frankie in Bombay sometimes it
can be a rolled-up sandwiches sometimes
it can be an enclosed sandwich what we
tried to do is make it ultimately
relatable to the LA market and make it
really similar to a burrito it's one of
the best things you've ever tried people
say never mix business with friends or
family I say don't knock it until you
try it the key members of the bumpy
Frankie company it's my sister Priyanka
our esteemed chef mr. Komal Jeet Singh
and our staff
having someone come in for the first
time who's never tried Indian food and
are completely engulfed by the
experience they truly realized that not
only is it an Indian food coming from a
gas station and being served in the gas
station that they would try it elsewhere
so by preserving traditional ingredients
traditional corporations traditional
recipes were staying true to not only
ourselves but the region of food for
which we serve and we want to make sure
that you're leaving feel like you got
the true experience for more clothes in
corriander head east to New York to a
place where the food is simply divine on
the surface the ganesha temple in queens
seems like just a place of worship for
hindus but if you take the side entrance
down the hall with all the lights follow
the signs down the stairs follow more
signs down more stairs you'll find the
temple canteen a restaurant serving food
to rival anything you would find in
india this is dr. uma Mysore Carter
namaste I'm the president of the Hindu
temple Society of North America in
Flushing New York the temple came into
existence in 1977 and as one of the
first of its kind in North America the
temple has become a cultural hub for
Hindus throughout the US this is a place
like home people who come to the temple
spend their whole day here they have
their worshipping services in the
morning and then very often we have
cultural programs but also they come
here to eat they come to the temple to
eat yes they do come here to eat some of
them come just only to eat not even to
come inside the temple so in addition to
a place of worship a community center
and a wedding venue the Ganesha temple
serves cuisine authentic to South India
and is open to the public and the food
is pretty fantastic
just as the New York Times for New York
magazine or Anthony Bourdain it's not
easy to find Indian food everywhere
around the corners so people come to
find authentic Indian food
okay so if you don't know anything about
South Indian food here are some of the
must-haves
there's vara I always called it as a
salty doughnuts Italy
there's nothing but puffed rice sambar
it is made of lentils very healthy and
most notably dosas there are at least
about eight or nine kinds of dosas
it consists of dow and there is a
filling inside we have about an
authentic Indian cooks in our Hinduism
we strongly believe without the offering
of food to the deities our prayer is
incomplete and that's how it really
started but I think when you go to a
canteen or a restaurant you want to
enjoy your food
we want to make sure that whether it is
a Hindu or a non him though you should
be able to enjoy the food who cares
really whether it is an Indian
restaurant or a non Indian restaurant
you just want to go and eat food so the
next time you're hungry in Queens try
the temple next a michelin-starred meal
that's actually affordable at a humble
spot in the middle of Singapore's
Chinatown
whoa michelin seek assurances Oh potato
so Fannin Longo Taleo adi sankara little
[Music]
washington jo han min-koo Shastri
vitreous our horses hie and elaine
shereika or insouciance life Shankaran
Pillai Singapore that's all Congress has
tree that's all today UTC person pursue
research on some little shop we drove us
over to trader 2003 so in the services
being delivered as a loggia
what a yo Qi Qi Liang Liang Shan Shan
Ito Chanel higher water stirring child L
to the cow to the Sangha Nyepi choice
and a towel cheetah
what's your engine
Hisle Georgia fan troll a traumatic
event or Java mentor Hondo cooker
tomorrow 77 Tony Leung chun-ying
Miccosukee yo yo yo yo can ye were
maintained as a family man ke my tau y
batata yo G the sources may chilling to
un like water self-enhancement way like
a schwa water Tom a healing service
Johnson sir on general sufficient alone
see ye and ye th the council the Joe
Garagiola know what honey oh yes it out
each head totally okokok a water so a
towel ah so what rating hyung-nim
Pechanga psychologically met thousand I
see yeah well I see yo the judge and
mayo Tania
water damage healing using the Cyril
Soho woloson we can determine that email
in child height or or to Sir Stephen the
control and since our woman only be
healing leasing yochim and finally a
restaurant that is so elusive the path
to find it becomes a journey all its own
this story is about a secret restaurant
in Madrid
oh yes tapas oh we are here for Chinese
treats whoa whoa whoa how did we get
down here again buckle up
that's a long story it all started when
we go to tip saying Madrid had the
secret Chinese restaurant the most
authentic food ever but very hard to
find let's go there was no email no
proper address all reviews pointed to a
mysterious underground location we call
the one number available no response
oh what a shame no wait we didn't give
up that easily
we got a friend in Madrid to get to the
bottom of it and she got us the right
directions
good thank you I got it I got it
there are no signs so follow these steps
we got to Madrid and followed the very
detailed instructions take notes people
go to Plaza de Espana Chuck get to the
southeast corner check find the parking
lot entrance go down the stairs
double-check oh look Assad's the
restaurant remember there are no signs
oh yeah forgot go down more stairs go
through the corridor welcome its whoa
wait
I think that's it that's how you find
cafeteria you lose ooh better known as
the salsa everyone me chilling zoo and
Lou Fink's or merciful to formally CT in
these Jews are some of the most genuine
Chinese food in Spain looks so good
tenderly me a woman would hear the howl
with Cynthia la ba la serda video -
these delicacies are not just your
average Chinese dumplings
they're from the couple's hometown
shin-chan in the surrounding province
Zhejiang in southeastern China it's
actually where the majority of Madrid's
Chinese population is from or may see
what's the warm ethnicity eisenbergers
so you want me to chant identity ha
located Almaty no to her and she went
along well you can see one like really
like it for a restaurant I was this hard
to find seems like this place never
stops going it's already deep in some
tofu you can you gotta tell us who does
your marketing
didn't wait until May or deep-well
ah come on man what about one for us
we'll take that as a maybe ah that was
totally worth the trouble
please can we start filming now I am
really hungry
[Music]